this video was made possible by
curiosity stream
watch an exclusive companion video to
this on nebula which you can access by
signing up for the curiosity stream
nebula bundle deal for 15
a year at curiositystream.com wendover
with any disruptive technology there's a
tipping point
there is a point in time when its path
towards market dominance
is a certainty now electric vehicles
are almost certainly a disruptive
technology they're almost certainly a
technology that will
with time become dominant over their
predecessor
in this case the predecessor is the
internal combustion car that you
yourself almost certainly use chances
are though
when asked you'd say that your next car
will not be electric
and you're right the average consumer
according to surveys
would not even consider purchasing an
electric vehicle
demonstrating that the technology is not
yet at the tipping point where it's on a
certain path towards market
dominance but again that path
is almost certain evs are not there yet
right now they're too expensive too
short range and too slow to charge
but they're close in fact research can
quantify
just how close they are it's been shown
that the tipping point price for evs
the price that will lead to mainstream
adoption and eventual disruption
is 36 000 taking a look at the prices of
the base models of three of the world's
best-selling electric vehicles
they're already roughly there so we know
that that's not what's holding
mass-market consumers
back what also matters is range
consumers say they need 291 miles or 469
kilometers of it
before the cars can go mass-market two
of the best-selling evs
the tesla model 3 and the chevy volt ev
are not far from that
while the nissan leaf lags behind range
and cost are closely linked and you can
essentially trade one off for the other
as the battery is the single largest
cost of an ev
that's why the industry is so focused on
innovating and scaling to lower the
component cost of ev batteries
and it's working in 2013 the average
price per kilowatt hour of an ev battery
was 668 dollars
meaning the base model tesla model 3's
50 kilowatt hour battery would cost 22
400 2 3 of what the vehicle sells for
nowadays the average price per kilowatt
hour is all the way down to 137
meaning that same battery pack would
cost just eight hundred and fifty
dollars
and this price per kilowatt hour is
expected to lower to one hundred dollars
by 2023
it's getting more and more possible for
manufacturers to sell an ev for the
magic 36 000
price with the magic 291 mile range
while evs are not quite there yet
they're really not far
and will be there in the next few years
so
range is not what's significantly
holding mass market consumers back
and it won't be at all within a few
years
what is though is charging the research
shows that consumers want to be able to
charge their cars from empty to full
in 31 minutes and that's the magic
number
for mass market adoption with this
current 36 000 evs just aren't
yet there the base model chevy volt ev
can't even fast charge it doesn't have
the technology for it
and even the upgraded more expensive
model that does allow for fast charging
can only get to 39 state of charge in 31
minutes
the nissan leaf does a little better
attaining 62
state of charge in 31 minutes well the
base model tesla model 3 does the best
with its ability to fill its battery to
in the most ideal conditions using the
fastest models of tesla superchargers
but that would only give it to 196 miles
or 315 kilometers of range
again in the most ideal conditions in
colder weather
both that charging time would be greater
and that range would be less
so it's currently possible to get an ev
with just about what the mass market
requires for cost and range
but reaching that charging time that's
just a lot
tougher what this research can lead us
to conclude
is that the largest barrier right now to
mass market ev
adoption is in fact the charging problem
the tipping points just will not happen
without widespread fast charging
but widespread fast charging is just
difficult
because of the very way our electric
grid
works you see back in the 1880s
thomas edison with his direct current
electric system
battled it out with george westinghouse
and his alternating current system
as the names suggest direct current
electricity flows consistently and
unidirectionally
while alternating current oscillates in
magnitude and rapidly changes direction
the exact details of how each works
isn't that important in this context
but what is is to know that for a
variety of reasons
ac power one it's now the standard for
power grids
but there are certain technologies that
still need
dc power the most widespread example of
that
is batteries you cannot charge a battery
using ac
power that's why you don't plug your
smartphone directly into an outlet
you plug it into a power brick that
plugs into an outlet
and that power brick is an ac to dc
converter
a standard iphone charging inverter
outputs 5 watts of electricity
which is plenty enough to charge the
phone's 11 watt hour battery in a few
hours
a base model tests the model 3 meanwhile
has a
50 kilowatt hour battery 4 500
times larger therefore it needs
a much higher wattage power inverter to
charge with any
speed it solves this in two ways
onboard that model 3 there's a 7.7
kilowatt inverter that can take ac power
from common sources
like a standard wall outlet and convert
it into dc
power to charge the battery at its max
rate this can charge the car fully
in under 10 hours and has the advantage
of allowing consumers to charge using
regular wall plugs
or by installing relatively inexpensive
chargers on existing domestic ac
electric circuits the disadvantage
though is that while
7.7 kilowatts is plenty fast enough for
regular
overnight at-home charging it's not fast
enough to compete with the convenience
of filling up an internal combustion car
at the gas station it's not fast enough
if you're on a long distance trip
and need to be able to gain hundreds of
miles of range in a matter
of minutes so if you need
more electricity faster you need a
higher wattage inverter
to be able to take a tesla model 3 from
almost empty to almost full in 30
minutes
you want between 120 and 250 kilowatts
the problem though is that a kilowatt
inverter costs
at least in this case 57 600
and is about the size of a very large
fridge
it's not exactly practical to have this
as an internal component
of the car so for faster charging
one needs to off-board the inversion
process
that's exactly what a dc fast charger
does
it applies a huge quantity of dc power
to the car which
bypasses the onboard inverter and
charges the battery
directly between the inverter the
charger and all the other equipment
needed for a fast charging station
the cost and size is not insignificant
one of the more popular models the
chargepoint express 250
which can charge a single car at a
somewhat slow 62.5 kilowatts
sells for 40 800
and that's before installation meanwhile
while it's tough to get an exact figure
industry experts estimate it costs tesla
about
two hundred and fifty thousand dollars
to build an average supercharging
station
with six to eight stalls delivering 120
to 150 kilowatts each
while its closest equivalent the
stations by volkswagen's electrify
america
are estimated to cost 350 000
but here's something counterintuitive
using
a 250 kilowatt charger versus a 150
kilowatt one
doesn't really impact how fast you
charge
batteries charge slower the more full
they are so the first
20 will pass far faster than the last
20 in the context of ev charging
this means that quite quickly into the
charge the speed
is impacted not by how much power the
station is putting out
but by how much electricity the battery
can accept
so it's actually faster to charge to 50
drive until empty charge to 50 and drive
until empty again
then charging to 100 and driving to
empty
a tesla model 3 can go from 0 to 50
charge in 15 minutes on a 250 kilowatt
charger
and 17 minutes on a 150 kilowatt charger
giving it enough range to drive at least
100 miles or 160 kilometers
while charging from 50 to 90 percent
would take an additional
27 minutes in both cases so
combining two charges from empty to 50
in two stops
you could effectively reach the tipping
point speed of 100
charge in 31 minutes with existing 250
kilowatt chargers
therefore what the industry needs is not
faster chargers but more chargers
which is hugely difficult given the
enormous cost
of fast chargers the average american
lives
four minutes away from a gas station
meanwhile
the same average american lives 31
minutes away
from their nearest tesla supercharger
currently there are 976 supercharging
stations in the u.s
each of which have anywhere between 2
and 56 individual chargers
in order to match the four minute
average of gas stations
tesla would need to build an additional
251 supercharging stations
at their 250 000 per station cost
that would cost the company some 7.8
billion dollars
or roughly 10 times their total annual
profits from 2020.
in addition only some 750 000 teslas
ever have been sold in the us meaning to
have fast charging stations
as accessible as gas stations the
company would need to install a 250 000
supercharging station for every 23 cars
it had on the road quite obviously
that's not feasible
as the stations would never break even
with such infrequent use
and that's the exact problem you need
the infrastructure to sell the cars but
you can't build the infrastructure
until you sell the cars it is the
classic
chicken and the egg problem there might
however
be a solution according to federal
government data
there are some 3845
non-tesla dc fast chargers in the us the
vast majority of which could charge a
model 3 within an hour
assuming it could connect just as there
was a format war in the 1880s between dc
and ac power there is now a war of
charging standards
take the example of selena kansas a
small city
off of interstate 70 which most people
only visit to refuel or
in this case recharge this supercharger
uses tesla's proprietary plug
this electrify america station uses ccs
and chatamo plugs
and this hotel's charger uses a j1772
plug
there are four different plug types in
one
small city now a tesla could use the
tesla charger and the j1772 charger with
an included adapter
but it could only use the chat amount
charger with a speed limited 540
adapter and it couldn't use the ccs
charger at all
as there's no adapter for that plug type
meanwhile
a chevy volt tv wouldn't be able to use
the tesla or chatimo chargers at all
as there are no adapters for either to
its ccs plug
that means that to accommodate every
vehicle type dc fast chargers need to
have
three different plug types which
overwhelmingly
they just don't especially along
interstate highways
there are the tesla stations and there
are the combo chademo and ccs stations
just like edison and westinghouse
delayed more widespread adoption of
electric power by competing against each
other
in these same areas with their different
incompatible ac
and dc standards different stakeholders
in the electric vehicle market are
competing against each other in the us
to create redundant largely incompatible
networks
but that's not happening everywhere you
see
in europe ccs is the standard
the european union has a directive which
means that many member states
by law require that public dc fast
charges
include a ccs pluck therefore in the eu
and neighboring countries like the uk
norway and switzerland
ccs is now the de facto or du jour
charging standard
that forced tesla's hand to the point
that in 2018
it retrofitted all its existing
superchargers with ccs plugs
switched its model 3s to ccs and
released an adapter
allowing its other models to use ccs
chargers
all told this means that pretty much any
car in europe can use pretty much
any dc fast charger that
combined with europe's higher population
density has helped ensure
that the density and coverage of dc fast
chargers
is much greater than in the us despite
the fact that ev ownership per capita
is actually higher in the us than europe
as a whole although certain european
countries far eclipsed the us's rate
europe is almost identical in size to
the u.s it has a very similar number of
electric cars overall
but it has double the number of dc fast
charging stations
in germany the furthest you can
seemingly get from a dc
fast charger is here in winterberg
from this small ski town the nearest
fast charger is about 30 miles or 50
kilometers away
in marburg meanwhile in the u.s if you
wanted to drive
directly from dallas to denver to major
american cities
using a base model tesla model 3 you
just couldn't
there's a 226 mile or 363 kilometer
stretch
with no dc fast charger between amarillo
texas and trinidad colorado
which given the elevation gain the car
would not
make while tesla is plugging this gap
soon with a new charger in clayton new
mexico
that won't solve the problem for every
single other ev on the market
since the charging systems are not
compatible
simply put mass market consumers are not
going to buy cars
that can't drive from dallas to denver
what europe has that the us does not is
coordinated
government plans germany's federal
government for example
builds its own charging stations in
addition to offering strong incentives
for private companies to do so as well
meanwhile the federal government in the
u.s has done very little to incentivize
fast charger construction
and certainly does not have a network of
its own
certain states such as oklahoma or
colorado
do have strong coordinated government
programs to build fast charging
infrastructure
meaning even shorter range evs can drive
essentially anywhere in each state
without encountering a fast charger gap
but the problem is that ev drivers from
colorado or oklahoma
will eventually want to drive through
kansas or nebraska
or wyoming or other states that do not
have a coordinated plan
the u.s federal government clearly wants
people to buy evs
because it offers hefty tax credits to
those who do so
but people are not going to buy evs
without the charging infrastructure to
support it
evs are comparable in cost to internal
combustion cars
their range is about what consumers
demand but what's lagging behind
is that charging infrastructure this
isn't even an exclusively american
problem
in australia one can't drive from perth
to sydney
the country's fourth and first most
populous cities in an ev
due to a massive charging gap while in
russia
despite similar incentives for ev
purchases there are a total
of 24 dc fast chargers in the entire
country of course some will always
debate whether governments
should be incentivizing electric
vehicles at all but regardless
of that they are it's tough to find a
developed country that does not have
some tax or other monetary incentive
for ev ownership the point is that
they're incentivizing the wrong way
evs are very very close to reaching the
tipping point criteria for everything
but charging cost is not standing in the
way
technology is not standing in the way
infrastructure is
so governments are putting the cart
before the horse
individual companies cannot reach the
required scale
and even if they did as the format war
in the u.s proves
it probably wouldn't be the kind of
scale that the mass market consumer
demands
individual car companies can deal with
making individual electric vehicles
attractive to consumers the government
doesn't need to worry about that
but infrastructure that's the
government's
job governments run or regulate roads
and bridges and tunnels and sidewalks
railways airports electric grids dams
sewers water supply networks and even
fuel supply systems because they are
infrastructure and infrastructure is
essential
so the only question is why not
charging so as you might have guessed by
now
i own an electric vehicle so i took it
to my local tesla supercharger to make a
companion video to this
where i give a super detailed super
nerdy explanation
of exactly how a supercharger works from
a technical perspective
you can find that companion video
exclusively on nebula
which as you probably know by now is
home to tons of exclusive
ad-free content from tons of your
favorite educational creators
the reason we can put companion videos
like this there is because of the way
nebula works
it doesn't have an algorithm to punish
us when we make something different from
our normal stuff
and the direct subscriptions from users
help fund both these and other projects
like our many nebula originals if you're
interested in watching
all this exclusive content plus
supporting loads of independent
educational creators
you can sign up using the curiosity
stream nebula bundle
basically you go to
curiositystream.comwendover
sign up for any subscription but i
suggest the yearly one since it's on
sale for less than 15
a year right now and then you have
access to both streaming sites
curiosity stream itself has great stuff
too from more established names like
richard hammond of top gear and grand
tour
who made a series about how weather
actually works by going
into extreme weather all told curiosity
stream is great thanks to their
seemingly
endless library of top quality stuff and
nebula is great
thanks to its exclusive early and
ad-free videos from the educational
creators you already know and love
curiosity stream and nebula together is
greater than great though
because it's only fifteen dollars a year
with the current sale
at curiositystream.com wendover